[Music]
my next guest is a comedian who can be
seen at the comedy cellar in new york
city this weekend and as the co-host of
the nikki and sarah show starting this
winter on mtv please welcome the very
funny nikki glazer
[Applause]
hello
how are you
me too me too
i flew here a couple days ago from new
york city uh whenever i fly my mom
always gets so nervous she's like will
you call me when you land so i know you
got in safely i'm like how about i don't
call you and you just watch the news
later
i feel like you might hear something
i have a roommate in new york she's not
there much anymore because she just got
a boyfriend you know or she's like super
missing but
i'm gonna hope for the best on that one
uh her parents keep calling they're like
have you seen her i'm like check
craigslist that's where i found her so
trying to help
i'd put up missing posters but she told
me not to use her printer without asking
so
my hands are tied you know
just like hers
[Music]
she's okay
before her i was living at home with my
parents at the age of 26 which is
embarrassing to admit unless you're
asian
it's totally cool in their culture
it means you're moving home to help out
when you're white it's just a step above
a homeless shelter
yeah it was bad i instantly turned back
into the teenager i was when i lived at
home in high school you know i started
shoplifting again
and that came back
watch out limited to
old habits die hard
i had to move out when my mom found my
vibrator
i had the same reaction i did when she
found cigarettes in my purse when i was
16. i was like mom it's not mine
i'm holding on to it for a friend
she had the same reaction too though
because she made me use it until i got
sick so
i learned i learned my lesson
yeah thank you
28 now
which uh as a woman is the age where
your body just starts to tell you to
have a baby
my hormones just like you have a baby
my bank account is like don't you even
think about it
don't you do it
bank of america emails me every day just
to let me know i'm broke
they're not even my bank so that's kind
of annoying
i know how i'm doing like i
last month i was window shopping at cvs
things aren't
good oh i was just tearing up in aisle
six
staring down a box of tampax pearls
just telling myself someday
you're gonna treat yourself like a lady
[Applause]
that is not an exaggeration i was saving
up for tampons because i remember having
the thought i hope i'm pregnant this
month i can't do it
that's insane
because i've had pregnancy scares uh one
time i just i told my mom right away
which i'll never do again
because she got excited
she was like oh my god i'm gonna be a
grandmother and i was like yeah until
tuesday
yeah
monday was a holiday yeah
i
i don't know that i would do that i uh i
probably would um
just because if i do one more i get one
free so i want to fill up the punch card
i
or is that frozen yogurt i get them
confused
there's just so much i want to do before
i have kids you know like die and i am
i don't know it's for me if i do do it
i'm going to go the adoption route i
know that you know and give them up for
adoption because i want to have them
i think they'll be cute they'll go quick
but um
but i ain't getting pregnant anytime
soon i have the best birth control now
um i'm uh practicing abstinence i
haven't had sex since december uh
because that's when i quit drinking so
that's
how that works
i needed to slow down though i added up
my number recently and you know the
number of people i don't
i don't like to say what my number is
i'll um
i like to say my number can drive
uh
a rental car so you know
that's different in every state
uh i didn't have sextiles 21 though um
because i was i was saving myself for
jesus which
luckily that was my gardener's name so
that worked out but uh
yeah i found a loophole in my dad's rule
um
he was pissed but i was like you hired
himself
i don't know why i waited and the first
guy was not special you know he was just
the first guy to have like a really good
argument for why we should
you know because i was like i don't
think i'm ready and he was like come on
thank you guys very much
that was great thank you that's
hilarious that's fantastic nikki glazer